hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well David Hume is
famous and rightly so for making the
claim that reason is and ought to be
only the slave of the passions which he
tells us in book 2 section 3 part 3 of
his treatise of human nature now this is
a very pessimistic view about human
reason and its capacity to engage these
other parts of ourselves that we call
the passions or emotions or drives or
desires isn't that but the picture is
not quite so stark as David Hume paints
it in this wonderful rhetorical passage
it's good to take a look at the context
of this he's he's talking about the very
possibility for what we call a conflict
between reason and passion something
that other philosophers and people in
ordinary life take us to be experiencing
a good portion of the time I am angered
by what I perceive to be an insult by
somebody but I think about the
consequences so I don't act
that anger I reason with myself oh I'd
better keep my anger in check or perhaps
they even reason in another way and say
perhaps that person didn't really mean
it is it rational to be quite so angry
maybe I should count to 10 right and I
thereby put that passion at least on the
side if not underneath the rule of
reason we could think of many other
examples having to do with other
emotions having to be you know present
with another person when you're feeling
sad or restraining the joy that you feel
over something that you think you
shouldn't feel joyous about and we could
go on and on and on
Hume is saying that these sorts of
conflicts always turn out to be one by
the side of passion as a matter of fact
you might say it's a no contest so he
says that you know we really improperly
speak of the combat of passion and
reason here's the passage reason is and
ought to be only the slave of the
passions and then he says and can never
pretend to any other office than to
serve and obey them now isn't that a
rather strange thing to say if it's so
intuitively obvious that this is the
case that reason can never do anything
other than serve and obey the passions
if that's the case then perhaps reason
is only a rationalization of what it is
that our emotions or drives or desires
or passions are bidding us to do and
whom says I realize that this is
somewhat extraordinary as an opinion so
we should confirm it by some other
considerations now he's saying other
considerations because he's already
brought up one really important
consideration and that is that reason
has as he calls it no original
influence on the will and thereby on our
actions that means that reason is not
able to originate not able to be the the
origin or font or you know a beginning
place for any of the decisions that we
make doesn't mean that reason plays no
role it just means that there always has
to be some emotion some desire some
thing that's moving us and then reason
discovers proper means to that end or
looks around for how you know something
can be brought about or compares things
against each other
perhaps that's we have a desire for
something and reason says aha this will
satisfy that desire but reason by itself
is unable to motivate us to do anything
according to two humans he brings up
another consideration which has to do
with the nature of passions what is a
passion he tells us a passion is an
original existence isn't that an
interesting turn of phrase he says or if
you will modification of existence now
what does he mean by that a passion is
something that is real it's something
that we feel within ourselves it's part
of our experience and it is what Hume in
other places will call an impression
there's a difference between the idea of
anger or a memory of being angry and
then actually feeling angry or feeling
desire or feeling fear and we could go
on and on through the entire list of
emotions if we want to by calling it an
original it means that it's not a copy
of anything else it is what it is and it
originates itself you might say we feel
what we feel
without it being merely you know
something that that is being produced
remembering that feeling in the past so
he says it doesn't have any
representative quality which renders it
a copy of any other existence or
modification this is a very important
point for Humes argument because it
lacks any representative quality the
anger the the hatred the sadness the
envy the the you know joy the desire the
love that I feel just is the emotion
that I feel he also says that here we go
when I am angry I am actually possessed
with the passion in that emotion have no
more a reference to any other object
than when I am thirsty or sick or more
than five feet high so not only does it
not have a representative quality human
so far as to say that these have no
reference to an object you might say
well that's a little strange
because when I'm happy I'm happy because
of X or X makes me happy humans say well
that's the cause of it but the emotion
itself you're not thinking about that
thing that you're feeling the feeling
right that's what the emotion is even
anger which is definitely an emotion
oriented towards something you're
feeling the anger and then you're just
kind of looking for things to be angry
at and you know the the anger itself
doesn't have any necessary reference to
an object for Hume that may be a little
bit of a stretch for some people when it
comes to philosophy of emotion but it's
very important to think about what this
actually gets him because there's no
representative quality and no reference
to an object
this means that strictly speaking reason
and passion they're not even on the same
playing field and they can't be opposing
each other so to use the anger example
he says tis impossible that this passion
can be a
opposed by or contradictory to truth and
reason since this contradiction consists
in the disagreement of ideas considered
as copies with those objects which they
represent so insofar as were feeling the
emotion the emotion itself cannot be
unreasonable
it cannot be contrary to reason it also
can't be reasonable it's just not
working in the same dimension as reason
or truth for that matter Hume would be
perfectly willing to say that our
feelings are our feelings and we feel
them and they're not even like true or
false insofar as they're our feelings
they just are their original existences
as he said now that presents a view of
reason and emotion and Moton and
motivation and we'll and human desire
and actions that seems to put reason
entirely aside and maybe in that case
reason really only can be the slave of
the passions first we have to feel
something we have to desire something or
be averse to something and only after
that can reason show up on the scene
sort of like a servant saying what is it
that you want you know boss or my lord
or you know I pick whatever lo Q shinu
you desire for that right but there's a
little bit more to the story the way
that humans is telling it to us here he
does tell us that emotions can in fact
be accompanied by a judgment or an
opinion and he says that nothing can be
contrary to truth or reason except what
has a reference to it and so the
judgments of our understanding have this
reference so passions can be contrary to
reason when they're accompanied by a
judgment or opinion now in this case
it's not the passion itself that is
unreasonable and being opposed by reason
it's the judgment or opinion so you
might say this is sort of an appendage
to the emotion and he says according to
this principle it is only in two senses
that any affection
activity can be called unreasonable what
could make a an emotion unreasonable
what could make as he's using examples a
hope or fear grief or joy despair
security unreasonable well when it's
founded on the supposition of the
existence of objects which really do not
exist so you know fear for example some
people are afraid walking into a room of
what might be in that room even though
the room is empty that it's an
unreasonable fear because they have no
good reason to think that the object
that they're afraid of spiders perhaps
are actually in the room and likely to
hurt them likewise grief right we can
say you feel bad about something some
loss that you had well what if you
didn't actually have that loss what if
you let's take a car for example you
forget that you left your car in a
parking lot somewhere and instead you
think you've left it outside of your
house and you walk outside you're like
oh crap my car isn't here you know and
you kind of look around go down the
street a bit oh my car must have been
stolen where could it be I feel so bad
well that that's unreasonable
because you're the dummy who left your
car in some parking lot somewhere as a
matter of fact I'll I'll tell you a
funny story about that I was working as
a security guard in a massive office
building and we had a few parking
structures and there was a man who had
parked his car in another parking
structure not one that we actually took
care of on New Year's Eve and he came in
I was working third shift around two
o'clock after you know having had a lot
to drink and he had found going back to
his car that the parking structure was
completely locked up and he could not
get his car and he was telling us about
it and we looked at him and we and we
said buddy
that's not our pocket parking structure
here's the number you can call but
you're going to get an answering machine
because it
new years and I don't got very upset
angry sad you know but but much of what
he was doing was quite unreasonable
none of his emotions were going to make
anything better he wasn't going to
affect us because we couldn't do
anything whatsoever and you're not going
to get in touch with anybody new year's
day to try to get your car out of hock
so we suggested to me find a hotel and
stay there
and I don't know what became of the man
but that would be a perfect example of
basing one's emotional reactions on
things that don't really exist they're
not really the case what's the other way
in which our passions can go wrong in
terms of the judgments that are being
made Hume says that sometimes we can
select insufficient means for bringing
about what it is that we desire or are
trying to avoid so it says in exerting
any passion in action we choose means
insufficient for the designed end and
deceive ourselves in our judgment of
causes and effects so if I'm in love
with somebody and really want to go out
with this person and I think that's
showing up at their workplace with the
boom box above my head like in that
silly 1980s movie is somehow going to
move that person to reciprocate my love
I am choosing means that are clearly
insufficient to that end I might do
better to I don't know ask the person
out or bring flowers or do something
like that another good example of
something you know perhaps at the other
end if I think that I'd like to go out
with somebody because I'm feeling
amorous towards them and I send them a
carefully worded email in the form of a
memo perhaps that's an insufficient
means as well and we could go on and on
and on you know people do this in terms
of anger thinking that the actions that
they're selecting are the proper means
for expressing or act
that anger only to find out that they've
gone way too far or attack the wrong
person or didn't go far enough
and didn't actually affect the person so
Hume thinks that those sorts of
judgments made following an emotion they
can certainly be off-base they can they
can be in conflict reason they can be
false now if that's really the case he
tells us that reason can in fact
demonstrate this to us
and these passion then will yield to
reason so it's not really the case for
Hume that that it's always still black
and white reason is and ought to be only
the slave of the passions sometimes
reason is sort of a slave in the sense
that it's looking out for the passions
best interests and helping those unruly
passions to find their way to something
better
and sometimes those passions will
actually yield to reason he gives you a
prime example he tells us that a passion
can never in any sense be called
unreasonable but when found in a false
opposition or when it chooses means
insufficient for the designed end it's
impossible that reason and passion can
ever oppose each other or dispute for
the government of the will in actions
how so reason tells the passions knock
it off he says the moment we perceive
the falsehood of any stop position or
the insufficiency of any means our
passions yield to our reason without any
position so in some respects Hume is you
know completely consistent in saying
that reason is always the slave oven
serves the passions but it serves it in
such a way that it might actually in
some cases bring about the cessation of
a passion that would seem to be opposing
reason but it'll be because we desire
something else instead so you could say
that passion still rules the game
you